if anyone can save arendelle and free
this forest it's you
elsa may have ventured into the unknown
and successfully escaped but we wouldn't
be surprised if fans of the frozen
franchise still feel like they're still
deep deep into the unknown especially
when it comes to the very confusing
backstory of anna and elsa's parents
to be fair frozen 2 gave us a whole
bunch of information
on not only the history of arendelle but
its former king and queen
yet somehow viewers were still left very
much in the dark about a lot of vital
information
did anna and elsa's mother ever have
powers what was exactly the mysterious
language anna and elsa discovered on
their wrecked ship
and what did it say we may not have
concrete answers but there are tons of
easter eggs and theories that might just
answer
what exactly disney is hiding about elsa
and anna's parents
i need to tell you about my past and
where i'm from
like many disney stories frozen opens up
with the tragic backstory of their
heroes
elsa and anna are seemingly normal
sisters except for one
tiny matter elsa has magical ice powers
they're also princesses destined to rule
a kingdom but that's pretty normal for a
disney film
while in the beginning her powers are
all fun and games and are actually used
to bond the sisters together
hence the whole junior snowman
and olaf scenario there's one night
where things take a dramatic turn
elsa accidentally strikes anna with her
powers and basically freezes her
luckily their parents are able to get
anna to the magical forest trolls just
before the ice reaches her heart
she's healed and anna is left with
little more than a gray streak in her
hair
we'll protect her she can learn to
control it i'm sure
but this was no joking matter to the
king and queen of arendelle
fearing the repercussions of how
powerful elsa is
they strip on of her memories and teach
elsa the mantra
conceal it don't feel it does anyone
else feel like this was a little bit of
an
overreaction i mean telling your
daughter not to interact with her sister
that's a little harsh why couldn't they
just warn anna instead
moving on in the story we see the last
of their dear mom and dad as they embark
on a ship
and say farewell to anna and elsa like
many disney movies the parents meet
their demise and on and outside are left
to fend for themselves and so
the hero's journey begins the question
is why exactly didn't they explain to
elsa what they knew about her powers
we find out in the second film that they
perished on their way to otta holland
but surely the information could have
been shared with their basically adult
daughters
what were they doing in the dark sea
i don't know incoming plot twist the
king and queen of arendelle aren't
exactly the heroes everyone
thought they were the backstory was kind
of confusing so let's go over what
frozen 2 showed us
ana and elsa's journey into the unknown
takes them to the land of north uldra
where the story about their land they
were told growing up
is actually all a cover-up decades
before the princesses were
ever even born arendelle's king set out
into the enchanted forest under the
pretense that he wanted to make peace
and set up a good relationship with the
north aldrin people
in order to do that he offered them a
dam which would supposedly strengthen
the power their land held
i wasn't at all prepared for what the
day would bring instead the king because
he believed their magic made them too
powerful
tricked his people into thinking that
the north aldrins had started a conflict
and a war broke out
both leaders perished but the spirits in
the forest became angry and trapped
everyone inside the woods with a magical
mist before anna and elsa arrived no one
had left
or entered in 34 years but before that
all goes down
north uldra's iduna saves the arendelle
prince agnar and together they escape
the two then marry and have two
daughters elsa and
anna whoa papa that was
epic so iduna and agnar just kept the
secret from
everyone their entire life they didn't
think that they should find a way to
save the people that were trapped in the
mist
i'm not sure about you but that doesn't
exactly sound like some hero behavior
we're pretty sure that if the movie was
about the former king and queen they'd
definitely be categorized as at least
an anti-hero luckily if we take a deeper
look at some hidden easter eggs and
interesting deleted scenes a lot of the
mystery surrounding iduna and agnar
and their actions can actually be
answered how did the ship get
through the mist i thought nobody could
but us
in frozen two there was originally
supposed to be a scene included that
would give insight into what anna and
elsa's parents were thinking right
before they embarked on their tragic
journey to otta holland
it was unfortunately deleted the
emotional scene opens with elsa using
her ice powers to channel the memory of
the water
and give anna one last glimpse of their
parents in a deep conversation the king
and queen discuss telling anna about
elsa's magic
it might be time to tell anna about elsa
i can't bear keeping her shut out
anymore
however the two still feared that
letting the two girls get close again
would cause elsa's powers to spin
out of control according to the deleted
scene even feeling joy could cause elsa
to spiral
alongside her powers this scene gave us
a glimpse into iduna and agnar's thought
process
making their decision to separate the
two girls in the first part a little
more clear they even agree on telling
anna right after they returned from
their trip to autoholland
so why on earth was this scene deleted
not only did it clear out that confusion
it also gave anna the closure that she
needed
her love could hold up the world it's
made pretty clear in the film that iduna
is pretty aware that she's from north
uldrath
not only does she have that classic
north ultra clothing but she also sings
a folk song
to elsa from her time growing up in the
enchanted forest
where the north wind meets the sea while
it might be easy to assume that agnar
knew about her history considering they
were married
we never get that confirmation she did
after all save him while he was
unconscious
you might say that he would have
questioned her knowledge of elsa's
powers
and how she knew to search for an answer
in otta holland but no one can say for
sure
so who is the real villain is it iduna
agnar
or both this is potentially a storyline
that could be cleared up in the third
installment
hey gail we're going for a ride wanna
come
going off of their failed trip to ottawa
holland we as an audience know how
dangerous it is because of the perilous
journey elsa takes to get there
not to mention anna literally almost
dies trying to save her sister as well
as olaf
thank goodness water has memory
considering iduna grew up learning about
autoholland and the power that lived
there she must have known about its
dangers
did she plan on taking her own daughter
there eventually that seems a little
careless on their part but maybe they
were desperate to save elsa from herself
no matter the cost
our only true hope of ever getting an
answer to these open-ended storylines
is a potential third movie and with how
successful the franchise is
we're betting there will be one so let's
take a look at some potential scenarios
that could bring us
more answers in another movie what is it
the truth about the past when elsa and
anna find
and then explore the shipwreck their
parents were on they discover a hidden
map in scripture
however it's in a language that neither
of them have ever seen before
we are made to assume that it is the
language of the north aldrin people but
it's never revealed could this
have just been overlooked by the
creators or could it be that what was
written on the map could be something
more
what if what's written on the secret map
reveals the location of their parents
who
actually never perished we do get to see
the shipwreck through the memory of
water again
and it may be grim to think about but we
never actually see their bodies
do you think anna and elsa's parents are
alive you are not responsible for their
choices elsa
another potential storyline in a frozen
three could definitely explore whether
or not anna and elsa's mom has powers of
her own
while the background information we get
on elsa's abilities is that she is the
fifth element that holds the rest
together
and not a genetic factor her mother did
grow up in north uldra
that means she was able to harness the
magic and protect it like the citizens
we met in frozen two
so would anna not also be connected to
the spirit elements
could their parents backstory
potentially open up a magical storyline
for anna or better yet a magical child
between anna and kristoff
you are the most extraordinary person
i've ever known
while this next theory may be a bit of a
stretch it's definitely possible
if you didn't know tangles rapunzel and
flynn rider make an appearance at elsa's
coronation
it's so small that if someone didn't
tell you you would probably miss it but
it's there there are plenty of fan
theories floating around that rapunzel
and anna and elsa are
actually cousins they look alike they're
royalty they have special powers that
have to do with earth elements
totally plausible people have been
wondering for years why tangled never
got the sequel it definitely deserved so
what if a third part of frozen was
actually a crossover this would also get
anna and elsa
more information on their family's past
and potentially give more backstory in
depth to the characters
this would definitely be something
completely different than anything
disney has ever done
but we wouldn't put it past them our
lands
and people now connected by love
some may argue that the story of anna
and elsa's parents was wrapped up with a
neat bow in frozen two
and that's definitely possible however
there were easter eggs left in the film
that hint at a sequel dealing with a
whole other set of parents
kristoffs we don't get much information
on kristoff's backstory besides him
being a sammy iceman
and raised by the rock trolls however
there's a major part of frozen 2 that
could hint at kristoff actually being
from north uldra
kristoff meets writer who lets the
audience know that the north aldrin
people have a long history of bonding
with reindeer
raising them as their best friends and
claiming to understand what they're
saying
sound familiar it's exactly what
kristoff does with sven
did i oh you do the best voices
while it could just be a coincidence to
give kristoff a mate
it makes you wonder whether or not
kristoff was orphaned because of
everything that went down with the
magical mist
maybe kristoff's parents were friends
with iduna meaning that kristoff may
derive from magic himself or
even more interesting what if kristoff's
parents are the next villains
this storyline could even tie in with a
movie focused around
anna and kristoff's wedding frozen two
left off with anna becoming queen and
the two getting engaged kristoff's evil
parents crashing their royal wedding
honestly sign us up we'll just have to
wait and see what the disney creators
come up with
and don't worry arendelle's doing just
fine keep looking after the forest
while the history of the king and queen
is definitely mysterious and complicated
we can't deny that disney did it again
it's yet another complex story to add to
their vault of huge box office successes
there's no way to tell what exactly
disney has in store for this franchise
but what do you think of anna and elsa's
parents were they heroes or
villains do you think a potential frozen
3 will reveal
any more info on them let it all go ah
pun intended
in the comments section below what are
your magical theories
also don't forget to give this video a
thumbs up and hit that subscribe button
for more content just like this
see you in another video